à l'emplacement de l'ancienne ferme du
pouls à poissy naîtra d'ici 2023 l'hôtel
le hameau 82 chambres deux piscines un
spa deux restaurants et un projet éco
durables jeudi 16 décembre dernier il
est entré dans une nouvelle phase avec
la plantation du premier arbre on
souhaite voir proposer aux gens quelque
chose d'un petit peu différente que ce
qu'on peut connaître dans l'hôtellerie
traditionnelle avec cet esprit maison de
vacances en effet où le week-end l'idée
c'est de venir de prendre d'avoir une
paire de bottes à disposition un anorak
de pouvoir se balader en famille de
déguster des bons petits plats de passer
un moment agréable autour de la cheminée
le projet est de par sa nature
complètement écocentres et dans la
proche on est dans un projet où on
souhaite à coeur les gens déjà dans un
cadre très naturel autour de l'hôtel un
grand terrain agricole est un art a
dédié aux sports équestres
professionnels et amateurs et à
l'élevage
c'est pas un club privé c'est un c'est
un hôtel près d'un art a ouvert à tout
le monde et voilà et je pense qu'il faut
en faire un lieu convivial show
chaleureux pour les gens qui sont
amoureux des chevaux situé à deux pas du
futur centre d'entraînement du paris
saint germain c'est un nouveau lieu
d'activités pour la commune pisciacaise
ici on est sur des terres agricoles
historique on est sur des espaces
céréaliers on est sur une bâtisse qui
est séculaire et c'est important de
poursuivre cette activité qui va mais là
la fois le développement économique est
préservé effectivement tout ce qui
concerne le défi de l'environnement
durable l'implantation d'un premier
arbre comme promesse et symboles au
total 6000 arbres vont être répartis sur
les 15 hectares de terrains du complexe
hôtelier